okay so the book of boba fett episode 2
just introduced a big character from the
expanded lore during the first part of
the entry we came face to face with two
of jabba's cousins and with them was one
of the most fearsome bounty hunters in
the galaxy a giant black wookie with
gladiator armor a massive rifle and
spiked knuckle dusters he certainly left
a massive impression without saying much
but who is he and what can we expect
from the character well throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
everything you need to know about him
and also talking about what you can
expect from the wookie if you don't want
any spoilers then i highly recommend
that you check out now but wookie this
way if you're up to date the thumbs up
is always massively appreciated and make
sure you subscribe for breakdowns on the
show every single wednesday without the
way thank you for clicking this may the
force be with you now let's get into the
breakdown
okay so like most wookies black
tresantan was born on kashyyyk the lush
forest greenland featured in revenge of
the sith and though the jedi managed to
defend it against the separatist army
things became messed up once the emperor
took over after the clone wars ended the
entirety of kashyyyk was enslaved and
this is why we see chewbacca chained up
in solo a star wars story now black
chris santan made his debut in darth
vader issue 1 which released in 2015
taking place after the first death
star's destruction this chronicles the
events in the star wars saga between a
new hope and the empire strikes back the
book also brought dr aphra to the
mainstream but we'll talk about her in
more detail later on in the video now
speaking of here if you just want to
know the wookie's origin story then you
should pick up dr aphra annual 1 as
that's where the majority of it is told
through the use of flashbacks like many
wookies chrysanthen is extremely strong
and vicious when pushed and this has
made him an incredibly sought-after
bounty hunter little is known about his
early life but we do know that he ended
up leaving because she can disgrace
rookies in general are a very
honor-driven species and black k was
somewhat of a rebel that went against
their ways time for a joke who's black
chris santan's favorite rapper
chupaca hey we're what a terrific
audience what a fantastic audience now
after learning a group of trained ocean
slavers were travelling to the planet to
capture fighters for their gladiator
matches he hatched a plan black k left a
dead wookiee as bait as he knew it would
draw them out and he began stalking
those that arrived chrysanthe killed
several of the slavers before capturing
one demanding that they take him off
world and to the shanti brothers they
were surprised to learn that unlike the
rest of the captives that he actually
volunteered but they quickly enslaved
him and put him to work the shanti
brothers ran a pit fighting tournament
which allowed him to become a master at
combat and over time he became one of
the most ferocious gladiators in the
galaxy during this chapter in his life
chrysanthe's hands were filled with
metal which allowed him to have
permanent knuckle dusters which is
something that will potentially pop up
in the show in episode 2 we can see that
he's wearing spiked knuckle dusters so
things might have been changed shipped
slightly for the live action version now
black k eventually earned his freedom
but he vowed to get revenge on the
shondy brothers and to hurt them much in
the same way that they'd hurt him in
rocky society there's something known as
a life debt in which a person must
return the same punishment that they
received this means that though black
hay won't kill them he will torture them
and he'll stop at nothing until the dead
is paid off grisantin was sold and after
gaining his freedom he became a bounty
hunter that worked for the crime lord
jabba the hutt he collected several big
prizes and chrysanthemum has sort of
been retrofitted into the star wars
cannon over the years he's gone up
against han solo and luke and there was
even a story in which he went toe-to-toe
with obi-wan being the lovable gangster
that he is jabber had started to tax
moisture farmers but one of these defied
him and actually stopped the payments
from going through jabba ordered
chrysanthen to track down a man who had
put an end to this and this led him to
the area in which obi-wan was currently
residing at turned out that it was him
who had stopped the war attacks and
crisentine took owen laws hostage went
into the desert and then made him scream
for help obi-wan appeared at this point
and the two went head-to-head now
obi-wan came out on top angra santan
ended up falling off a cliff he fled the
planet for some time and this incensed
jabba but eventually the two ended up
working together again now this actually
takes place in star wars issue 20 if you
want to read the full fight and it's
definitely worth checking out now i'd
actually love to see this play out in
the obi wan kenobi show which we know
we'll be releasing soon on disney plus
with him working alongside jabba's
cousins and also being on tatooine there
are many ways that they can tie things
together and i'd love to see some
prequel elements in that series that
help set up things that happen in the
book of boba fett however as we saw with
kobanth when characters are brought
across from the expanded lore certain
things have changed about them to fit
the disney plus shows so who knows if
the last storyline will take place now
after the battle of yavin darth vader
arrived on tatooine in order to broker a
deal with jabba and the empire during
this vader requested that jabba supply
him with two bounty hunters to carry out
jobs for him jabba gave him fett and
chrysanthe but judging by episode 2 it
doesn't seem like they've ever met
however they might reveal that the two
have worked together before but yeah
it's that whole murky thing where disney
are just changing what they want now
fett went off to find luke skywalker and
chrysanthen was tasked with tracking
down an agent of the emperor in the
darth vader comics especially they make
it very clear that vader and palpatine
are pretty much always trying to screw
the other one over and they're
constantly spying on each other to see
what they're up to palpatine of course
had several apprentices taken out by
other characters that then replaced them
and as we saw in return of the jedi
vader wanted to use luke's help to
overthrow his rule now the agent was
called silo4 and chris santon managed to
capture him and take him to vader
however he himself never found out the
information that vader was after but the
galaxy's biggest deadbeat dad did
appreciate him completing the task and
the skill it took now it's during this
time that he also met dr aphra as sort
of indiana jones for the star wars
universe aphra is a female archaeologist
that made a task with doing specific
missions and she became one of his most
trusted allies however she ended up
falling out of favor with vader and the
character faked her own death in order
to hide from him she should have just
went back to where he grew up you know
just sat around with owen laws as he'd
never think of looking there the idiot
anyway i think she's got a high
possibility of showing up in the series
2 and though there haven't been any
casting announcements for her if black k
is here i can imagine she is too now
aphra actually coined the nickname black
k and also bk but the guy isn't flipping
burgers what now she and chrysanthemum
ended up working together and alongside
bee box boss and ig90 they carried out a
heist shortly after this he then
traveled to vrogas for us in order to
capture luke skywalker chrysanthemum
ended up attacking the millennium falcon
and even duked it out with chewbacca
just before the fight chewbacca had
actually been poisoned and nurse
chrysanthen easily bested him as he went
to kill solo c3po intervened and chris
santon punched him having knuckle
dusters built into his hands caused a
reaction though and chrysanthemum was
electrocuted by the droid now
chrysanthemum was spared and his next
job involved him bringing an afra deader
alive chrysanthemum tracked her down and
he ended up taking her to vader's
flagship which was called the executor
she was shot into space as part of her
dunder dern execution but chrysanthemum
actually ended up rescuing her now that
she'd bring you fully up to speed with
the character and going forward we know
that in the year 9 bby that he's working
for the hud twins who are of course the
cousins of jabba dr aphra is not in
sight but we do know from the expanded
law that the pair ended up working
together at several points now no one
really knows what happened to the pair
afro that but it's clear they've gone
their separate ways under the employ of
the two huts he's very much used as a
means of intimidation and i actually
think going forward bubba will take out
the pair and he'll end up working with
big k in order to form a new crime
syndicate you have to remember he's a
bounty hunter at the end of the day and
due to his skills i think he'll be
highly sought after by phet now i hope
that they keep him around for a while
and it would be great if he also showed
up in the ob1 series to bring their
showdown from the comics to life either
way i'd of course love to hear your
thoughts on the character and also what
you think he's gonna be doing in the
series as a thank you you'll be entered
into a competition and we're giving away
three copies of an mcu boxer of your
choice on the 30th of january all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the
character we picked the comments at ryan
i'm at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one on screen right
now so that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of episode 2
of the book of boba fett which will be
linked on screen right now it's some of
the best star wars i've ever seen and
it's also packed with a number of deep
car easter eggs that we break down for
your viewing pleasure if not then thanks
for sitting through the video may the
force be with you always and i hope you
have an awesome week you take care of
yourself peace